[Music]
hey man with
record-breaking 864
insect tattoos 800 of them [ __ ] the
mothman i didn't know there i didn't
know there were that many insects i was
trying to be a bug trap i don't know if
it's like necessarily he had different
species but he just happens to have 864.
does he look like that fly strip that
you see sometimes at a restaurant
a yellow strip he looks like this he
just likes bugs huh
whoa that is a lot of bugs and the irony
of this he has a guinness world record
for it oh he's a bit he's a big like
centipede on his channel that's ironic
about that he hates bugs oh that's that
is ironic is he asian like he just wants
to do some self-hating [ __ ] no
asians are the only self-hating race you
know asians are like they like put
themselves through pain and [ __ ] because
they know it's supposed to be good for
them so they're like you know they get
[ __ ] they walk on rocks and [ __ ]
punch
themselves it's supposed to be good for
you they do battering rams on their
penises yeah they do all kinds of stuff
mostly with penis yeah like we're the
only i think we're the only race that
goes to the massage place and go
[ __ ] me up
bro
you haven't watched a lot of white guys
getting their [ __ ] balls kicked by
chicks i've seen videos about this what
about jackass but that's like fun though
they make money well they monetize that
you know what it is then it's it's
everyone gets into pain but then white
people know how to have fun with it yeah
they make it fun and enjoyable the
challenge monks that punch their balls
it's like they want to be cool but it's
like you're still punching your balls
yeah don't you know you're just a gif
please like you couldn't master anything
else just whatever happened like kung fu
imagine being like a your lifelong
dedication is to get a battering ram on
your dick and blocking that [ __ ] and all
it be all it turns into is a gif
that someone posts when they're like my
bosses i have to say an hour later
that's your [ __ ] life experience
mondays am i right
or like i'm a girl and this boy is
getting paid 56 000 more per year than i
am
boom boom boom boom boom
that's pretty tight though oh man did
you did you see that um the north korean
president uh presentation for kim
jong-un like the military yeah and
they're like breaking rocks on their
chests and it's like dude it's really
intense like it's like a dude will just
stand there and then everyone has actual
sticks and they're just whacking but
what it looked like was like the old
mortal kombat movie you know like it was
like a scene it was it was supposed to
show how powerful they are but i was
just like come on man he's not doing
this that in the 80s it was like wow
yeah but it's like now it's like man
that's just mcdojo [ __ ] bro nick dojo
it's true it is
it's like magic yeah they're just doing
magic dude no because you have the ufc
like oh that's what the real fighting is
yeah but that's like some sometimes you
don't need to see a person david blaine
magic is [ __ ] like for them they're
doing this to me
what's that old asian guy's name i don't
know if he's chinese japanese or korean
but um
i i i know you're dangerous no i don't i
know he's not korean can i just say as a
white person that was racist
i i know he's not korean but i didn't
want to not say korean and make it seem
like i don't like japanese chinese
people it's not what it is but this
guy's old and he's a martial artist and
he just does this and people fly back oh
i know you're talking about he like
looks at people yeah but he does it so
there's a lot of asians that that con
people but what's funny is they set up a
fight
with like a mma guy it's [ __ ] aikido
dude
no but aikido but no this but there's no
uh offensive moves like a chi master
he's doing this and people are flying
back but it works oh they did it in
japan but they also did one in china so
if it's if it's if they're wearing like
a karate outfit yeah that's a japanese
one okay yeah i think it's a japanese
guy and so they fought mm they he fought
it i mean someone set it up and i
thought that's mean whoever set this up
from his camp
dude like an anime that didn't want to
hit him because he knew it was bull yeah
but so they're like just you know fight
fight and he punched him dude you know
knocked the guy out like down and he got
because he's doing this so the first
time he does it the guy doesn't move
so as he's approaching he's doing it
faster and faster
like oh my god and so i was like dude
what are you like what are you doing
like
he's so delusional i think if it's the
same one the mma guy hits him once drops
him and he goes over and he's like i'm
are you okay are you okay right and then
the guy's like no no we're gonna keep
going
and then he's like are you sure yeah and
then he's like all right and then he hit
him again he goes nah i'm not doing this
anymore yeah i blame people from that
guy's camp because
they have to know this not real this is
the longest troll the entire martial
arts studio and his students are like
hey hey let's play a trick
is worldwide though they have so many
different like in indonesia they
actually have a really bad issue with
this stuff where they have this fake
martial arts stuff where they they use
like dull blades to like slice somebody
and they could show that like i did not
get cut yeah but there's all these
little kids that try to do that
they slit their own throat or they they
they like drive like cars over people
to show that like i'm invincible you
know and then other people try to do it
and then they [ __ ] kill them and this
happens over and over and over that
video of the cat who uh he was like in
jail for a while but nobody knows that
at the time and he's on this um show and
james randy is there james randy's like
a big magic debunker because oh yeah
like he well he wasn't a magic debunker
but he was like hey magicians are like
just doing tricks he's the guy that was
like i'll pay you a million bucks
exactly if you can show me like actual
extra like paranormal activity or
whatever
says cat would he had a phone book and
he would like open the phone book up and
then he would like do all this [ __ ] he's
like wearing a ghee he's like some white
dude looks like me with a [ __ ]
mustache and he's like wearing a key
he's like doing [ __ ] around the phone
book and he like gets down here and then
he goes like
and then the phone book page turns over
and james randy's like okay cool let's
see
yeah let's see you do it again so he
puts all these like little like um
flakes around the thing where it's like
they're weightless right so like if you
were to blow next to them it would like
he's like i just think he's blowing on
[ __ ] he's like he tells the camera he's
like i think he's bone and [ __ ] we'll
see and then the cat he's like doing all
this stuff again he's like in this geez
i don't know the energy's not here
energy the energy's gone
it's the energy charlatan they say it's
all gone
they like to say their their chi
yeah is depleted now because he used so
much in the first one to move that one
he comes out later just admits his whole
[ __ ] scam and he was just blowing on
on paper but he got all these people to
believe it because he looks like he's
not blowing he like really does he did
match with this thing we kind of want to
try that
like and just blows on it and it goes
over and he's like see you guys got a
phone book here i'm fascinated by the
people who start to believe their own
[ __ ] though because the con artists they
actually make logical sense they're
trying to make money they're trying to
do their thing but the guys that are
like these magicians that actually
believe they're chi fighters
and then also they're followers that
shit's crazy because because they're
doing this [ __ ] and then they're like oh
[ __ ] like they haven't had one person
that was like oh i'm gonna try this out
and then when they do the demonstration
of like all right hit me and then they
do their [ __ ] thing like do they like
for the instance of the guy the japanese
guy that does this do they really need
to get an mma fighter to fight him they
could have just got some regular guy
just to blow up and just punch him in
the [ __ ] head let's go punch that guy
it makes it legit that makes it legit
you know it makes it so much funnier
though
when they get punched and they're like
no the [ __ ] lightning is not working
yeah but that's like seagal because you
guys watched segal lawmen yeah it was
like an a e show or something yeah
he was like a real cop he was yeah he
was a real cop for the louisiana parish
he's like a lot of people don't know
this i've been a cop for 25 for [ __ ]
[ __ ] five years
okay and then he's in there and like all
the cops are just like yo this seems
called we've never seen a real celebrity
in our whole [ __ ] lives and like this
is crazy and then he's like okay i would
like somebody to burnish a weapon upon
me right now
and then a guy like takes out a gun like
okay make a gun
see how i'm disarming this guy right now
i'm disarming him so easily i'm
disarming it and everyone he's just
talking so much that he's not even
looking yeah and then this guy's just
like in odds like wow the girl's
touching me this is crazy and also
steven seagal is like six five and like
300 pounds his gut's like hitting this
guy in the head like right here his
head's getting hit with his gut so it's
just [ __ ] but it's just clearly just
star power happening and like this these
people are not on like wow this is
amazing stevenson hey star power is
power it is it is but he was also um
he's also like what six something right
and a lot of his opponents were like
five two japanese dudes so his aikido is
always gonna work it's sick dude right
he's just flipping [ __ ] or like
the detroit urban survival
training guy have you guys seen that the
black dude put that with the headset a
headset and he shows people how to oh
yes
everyone has seen this i already love it
he's really good he has some really high
level technique have you seen the guys
that um they they took debunk those like
the defense videos like they actually
shoot yeah you know and like so they're
like okay this is if i was in a real
situation and you come up to me boom
you're dead and they're like they're
boom you're dead like you know it's too
late you're too late because they'll try
to do all this stuff to get the gum out
and they're like no boom you're dead
yeah there's like some asian kid that
went to go visit him and then he goes
all right shoot me
and then he the the detroit guy moved
too slow and he blasted him like five
times
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you know like in the movies when like
someone they had a gun in the back and
then like they they do that you know
they they get the gun whatever and like
you know we learned that in tackling the
two it's the one motion thing but
if the gun's already cocked it's just
like and you're dead if you put your so
put put you just gotta do that
it's very clear you gotta know exactly
where the pressure is and then and when
they're gonna when they're gonna shoot
yeah yeah and so if you watch if you
watch the documentary remo williams
he teaches you that you have to hear
like the tendons in the finger no
[ __ ] you have to hear
those attendants
these guys have the biggest [ __ ] in the
universe you saw the documentary
williams you don't hear the tendencies
they had
they had a korean master played by a
white guy this is back then when you
could do that would you do that and then
like he's like you must hear and his
accent was like somewhere between
chinese and japanese it wasn't so cool
there was a white guy that played him
how long ago was this wow this is like
in the 80s oh cause like tom cruise in
the last samurai was like 10 years ago
i think you can still do it
but this is the best explanation of how
to dodge bullets is you have to hear the
tendons in the fingers
fingers no joke when he would dodge it
like i don't want to be like
he'd be like this
and then like he would get closer and
he'd be like yeah he'd get closer again
then he would disarm the guy but what if
you're at a range and you could barely
hear anything well then what if you're
at a rave he would tell you i don't go
to rape that's what he would tell you
but he's a white guy why are you there
anyways yeah while you're at rape it's
no good nothing would happen after 12.
[Music]
[Music]
you